now what i'm required to prove
is that um
for n equals k plus 2 which is the next
step um i have to say that s
of k plus 2
is going to be greater than or equal to
k plus 2 factorial all right how do i do
it
well what i'm going to begin with um
just like i did for an earlier part in
the question i'm going to say let's just
have a look at the left hand side
there's so many ways you could do this
right but i think that working with the
left hand side is going to be fairly
straightforward because it will allow me
to use the inductive hypothesis very
directly okay so i'm going to consider
the left hand side
it's equal to s of k plus 2. well from
the question by definition you look at
the previous term that's sk plus 1
and then you multiply by that same
subscript and then you look you multiply
that by the term before so
here was the previous term and there was
the term before that okay
now based on the inductive hypothesis
right here and i'll just highlight it
just to make it very obvious right what
i can do is i can replace my sk and my
sk plus 1 with something smaller these
square roots of factorials right so
since i'm replacing it with something
smaller i'll pop in the greater than or
equal to sine
here comes this term here it's going to
be this term here
is going to be smaller than this term
here
and then i've got a k plus 1
and then this term here whoopsie daisy
my pencil is playing up today
this term here is smaller than this term
here so that's why the inequality
is preserved so i'll just highlight
those that's the comparison that i'm
making
okay
pause right from here there's not many
lines of working if you know the
direction to helpfully go in right
but if you are just kind of blindly
simplifying um you're just going to go
round and round in circles so
look at this line carefully and think
about what we can do to it that will
sort of um get us helpfully towards the
goal okay
remember this is the goal here we want
to have something like the square root
of k plus 2 factorial on the right hand
side or something bigger because then i
can just have a chain of inequalities
how am i going to do that well um we've
already used the inductive hypothesis
and i should say that shouldn't i i
should say by assumption here we go
so we've all already used that so in
order to try and um go further i need to
either put draw on some stuff i know
about inequalities and
real numbers and algebraic
properties in general or i look to the
question for some clues and i hope you
remember this is part three of a
three-parter so you've got part one and
part two sort of nestled there which
even though let's just go back
even though part three does not
explicitly say use part one or two um
you should kind of always assume that a
multi-parter is there to to get you to
refer to those earlier steps um which is
very fitting for a question by of proof
by induction right see what i did there
now
part one uh it really was just a warm up
it's just like can you understand how
this thing works part two is the key and
you should be able to recognize that
because you've got an inequality here
and part two was also an inequality and
look it's got square roots flying around
in it it's clearly going to be useful
here okay so let's go back to my working
for part three
and what i'm going to jot down here on
the side is that result that i just
proved earlier on it's that the square
root of x plus x is greater than or
equal to the square root of x
x plus 1.
how can i manipulate what i have on my
right hand side here in order to use
this part 2 result
what i see is that
because of the direction of my inner
coordinates right what i want is to be
able to replace this
with something smaller right so uh you
can see on the right left hand side here
of this inequality i can make this
statement if i can find this over here i
can replace it with something smaller
namely what's on the right hand side so
in other words i'm looking for
something of this format right uh square
root of x plus x kind of thing right
can i find something
and the sum
added to
its own square root somewhere on the
left hand side or somewhere on the this
right hand side i should say and
hopefully that kind of clue is enough
for you right there's only on on this
right hand side there's only one thing
that is not underneath the square root
there's only one thing that could be the
candidate easily anyway for this x term
and that is
this x this k plus 1. you see that
that's the only thing that's not under a
square root so it is our best candidate
to be x so long as i can have that k
plus 1 and a square root of k plus one
then i should be able to you make use of
this um of this result in part two and
hopefully you can see without too much
difficulty there's a k plus one right
here
there is also a square root of k plus
one just hiding underneath this first
term i just need to tease apart i need
to unroll this factorial just a little
bit okay so let's go ahead and do that i
can say
square root of
let's write in purple because i've used
purple in the previous line square root
of k plus 1
factorial is by definition k plus 1
times k factorial right
complete the square root over there
and then you've got uh everything on the
right hand side which i haven't
touched so i've got my k plus 1 right
there and then i've got the square root
of k factorial there okay now what's
great about this is you can see number
one
um here are the two bits that i was
looking for right
here's the k plus one that i saw
not underneath the square root and then
here's the square root of k plus 1 it's
just got this extra term that i can just
factorize out right and what's even
better is that the thing to factorize
out
is square root of k factorial is over
here as well so therefore i'll have a
common factor which is even better
so let's make that obvious because i
need to um this is a proved question
right i'll break this
square root into two square roots
like so
everything over here is unchanged
then i can factorize out this uh here we
go this square root of k factorial which
leaves me with the k plus 1 terms by the
by themselves okay so let's just put
that i'll put that square root of k
factorial in green because that's what i
just highlighted it with
and then here comes some big brackets
you've got the square root of k plus 1
and then you've got k plus 1 there's the
factorization so you can see all those
lines of working were to get me into
this format right here you can see that
this
is parallel to this it's just that why
is that so messy there we go
this is my square root of see daisy
this is my square root of x plus x it's
just that x equals k plus one all right
so i'm pretty much ready to go right
this is um this is the conclusion i'm
just going to use part two at this step
here it's the square root of k factorial
um if let me just drag this with us so
we can see it in the working
if i'm saying that x equals k plus 1
what happens when you substitute into
the right hand side and and use that
result you're going to have the square
root of
x is equal to k plus 1 so there it is
and what is x plus 1 well that's k plus
1 plus 1. so it's k plus 2 and then i
complete the square root there and
you're like oh sweet like that's kind of
it right look at what i was required to
prove it's k plus 2 factorial there it
is k plus 2 times k plus 1 times k
factorial so that's it square root of k
plus 2
factorial i've got an s k plus 2 on the
left hand side which left was left
unchanged
as required
so
full stop unfinished i guess i should
just conclude
just by saying that i've invoked the
principle of mathematical induction
there's no long essay required like
there was back when i did mathematical
induction
okay so
i hope you found that helpful let me
just conclude by saying like let me sort
of tie this up in a neat bow right at
the beginning i said why would i give
you a question that i am very confident
you will not get this exact format
question i think it would be exceedingly
cheeky if this year's hsc exam committee
gave you a second order recursive
formula and asked you to prove it by
induction the way that we've just done
even though i don't think you will get a
second order recursive formula because
look the syllabus very explicitly calls
out first order right and it doesn't say
like oh you can't use second order but
if they were going to
just let them
give you whatever order recursive
formula they wanted they probably
wouldn't have explicitly called out
first order recursive formula right
so why am i assigning this question even
though i'm confident you won't get this
exact type well i think even though you
won't get this exact type of question
the style of question is something you
will encounter by which i mean this is
an application of familiar knowledge
proof by induction
in an unfamiliar context because you
have to do this second order thing right
it changes your test uh and assume steps
the steps that you're used to doing on
like mental autopilot you're like ah
there's no real thought needing to be
applied in the test and assume steps but
actually there are and what i i don't
want you to come away from is saying oh
mr wu said we if we get a second order
recursive formula all you need to do is
like the rule is you just have to test
two things and assume two things right
that's not what this is about what this
is about is did you know
the point of having an assumption in the
in proof by induction at all like why do
we do that and the answer is we do an
assumption because that's the foundation
that you lay to do your proof step right
well if your proof step is going to go
two steps back
your assumption will also need to go two
steps back because those are the two
steps that are going to be your
foundation for your proof step right so
if you really understood what the assume
was about then you would have
reflexively said oh i need to do two
cases here and not just one i need k and
k plus one and then my proof step will
be k plus two right so it's not about
memorizing yes for a second order you do
two steps it's about do you really know
why there's an assumption do you really
know why you would use the exponential
form of a complex number rather than the
polar form um the trigonometric form do
you really know why will we express
vectors as like you know a b with a with
a line over it or why we would um you
know just use the a single point and a
single you know indication to have
position vector or displacement vector
do you really know why the dot product
is so useful then you'll know when to
apply it that's what this question is
really about